- Thank you for coming out
on a really, really unpleasant afternoon.
You've done us proud.
This is actually the largest event
that the Peabody has held
since COVID by numbers.
(audience claps)
So give yourselves all a pat on the back.
- Really delighted to see you here.
I'm Chris Norris,
I'm the Director of Public Programs
at the Yale Peabody Museum,
and on behalf of Yale
University and the museum,
I'd like to welcome you
to the inaugural John Ostrom lecture.
I'd also like to take
this time to acknowledge
as we sit here on Yale's site,
that indigenous peoples and nations,
including the Mohegan,
Mashantucket Pequot,
the Eastern Pequot, the Schaghticoke,
the Golden Hill Paugussett, the Niantic,
and the Quinnipiac and other
Algonquian-speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations
the lands and waterways
of what's now the state of Connecticut.
And we honor and respect
the enduring relationship
that exists between these peoples
and nations and this land.
This is the first in a
series of annual lectures
that honor the memory of John Ostrom.
John was a longtime curator
of vertebrate paleontology
at the Peabody Museum, an
outstanding paleontologist,
and a man who I think it's fair to say
profoundly transformed
our view of dinosaurs.
And it gives me great
pleasure to introduce
one of John's successes, Professor Bhullar,
faculty member in the Department
of Earth and Planetary Sciences,
and a curator of vertebrate paleontology
and vertebrate zoology
at the Peabody Museum
to introduce this year's speaker.
Thank you.
(audience claps)
- Well, welcome everyone again
to the first John Ostrom lecture,
which I hope is a first
taste of the new Peabody,
which will to be opening in early 2024
with galleries completely redone,
about 50% larger than before
and it will be completely free.
We've got new mounts of
just about everything,
a new K to 12 education center.
Can't wait to welcome you there.
So fossils are part of the
stony fabric of our planet.
They're component of what
we call the rock record,
and in that way they're geological,
both in the compositional sense,
in the sense that they're
studied by geologists,
but they're also part of
the book of life's history
and are in that way biologic
and can be viewed through
a biological lens.
To be a paleontologist is to
try to straddle both worlds,
often badly, always uncomfortably,
but there's some who truly master this.
OC Marsh and John Ostrom
both were able to muster
their knowledge of the living world
to gain insight to illuminate
the lives of extinct animals.
In fact, I think Ostrom's finest work
was his work on the evolution of flight,
which was so informed by the behavior
of living birds, living bats.
Ostrom had the great insight that birds
are descended from dinosaurs.
And a successor here at Yale, Godiet,
who's in the audience today,
showed rigorously that birds are dinosaurs
and that the characteristics
of extinct creatures
can be inferred from a particular kind
of systematic examination
of their living relatives.
But no one in the modern
age, in my opinion,
has done more for the
understanding of dinosaurs
and other extinct
vertebrates as living animals
than Professor Lawrence 'Larry'
Witmer of Ohio University.
Larry is an anatomist par excellence,
and that is perhaps to
me the highest compliment
one can pay a biologist,
for anatomy is 3D,
nay 4D structure and is the basis
of everything living things can do.
Consider that even the
twistings and foldings of DNA
are anatomy writ small.
The hardest problems in the
life sciences and medicine
have to do with biotic
geometry, with space and time.
Larry has his bachelor's from Cornell,
Masters from KU, PhD from Johns Hopkins.
He holds the Chang
Ying-Chien Professorship
of Paleontology at Ohio
and he's published
numerous groundbreaking,
I would say, discipline-creating papers
in all the most exclusive
scientific journalists.
He's appeared National
Geographic, CNN, NPR,
media around the world.
He is highly dedicated
also to public education
at all levels.
His scholarly work has
been a primary inspiration,
maybe the primary inspiration
for my own lab's work here at Yale.
And so it's with very great
pleasure that I, that we,
give him to you for Professor Witmer
is a living time machine
who will bring you
as close as one can come to dinosaurs,
not buried in the earth,
but alive here before you
once more Larry, my friend.
(audience claps)
- Well, thanks Anjan.
I hope I can live up to that introduction.
It is a tremendous honor for me
to be invited to give the
inaugural John H Ostrom lecture
here in the the glorious
OC Marsh lecture hall
right next to the legendary
Yale Peabody Museum.
We all can't wait for that to open,
and you should all be thrilled
that it's actually
gonna be free admission.
That's a wonderful thing.
So the wonderful thing about John Ostrom
is that I actually knew John Ostrom.
I got to know him during my visits here
to the Peabody Museum, I'd
see him at conferences,
I took this picture here back in 1985
when I was a Master student
at the University of Kansas.
John Ostrom has always
been sort of a hero of mine
when I was growing up, so
it kind of blew my mind
when I would go to a conference
and he'd walk up to me
and go, "hi, Larry!"
I'd go like, "John Ostrom knows my name?
And he wants me to call him John?"
Just couldn't quite handle that.
And it turns out that we're related,
at least academically.
(audience laughs)
John Ostrom did his PhD
work under the mentorship
of Ned Colbert at the American
Museum of Natural History.
Later John was the PhD
advisor for Peter Dodson
and who was in turn the PhD
advisor for Dave Weishampel,
who was my PhD advisor at
Johns Hopkins Medical School.
So that would make John my
academic, great grandparent
And that's an amazing picture,
except I really wish I were in it!
There, I fixed it.
(audience laughs)
You do what you can.
So I'm not gonna fully recount
John's illustrious career,
but I do wanna point out out
why his work is so revered.
Many, many achievements,
certainly many contributions,
but he was a key player
in two major debates,
both of which have been so
important and transformative
for our discipline.
One was the origin of birds
needed absolutely seminal
work on Archaeopteryx.
And he was a major player in
the sort of the revolution
in dinosaur physiology and behavior,
drawing largely on his
work on Deinonychus,
a dinosaur he discovered and named
and which really is the model
for the raptors of "Jurassic Park."
And so we are here to sort of, in a sense,
celebrate John Ostrom's work,
and so what I'd like to do today
is show you how we get inside
the heads of dinosaurs.
If we're interested in dinosaurs
as living, breathing animals,
we do have to sort of look
beyond the bones themselves
to see what the bones can tell
us about the soft tissues,
the muscles, blood vessels,
nerves, brains, skin,
the clothe that animate the skeleton,
the features and the biology
that time has stripped away.
Really, ultimately it comes down to
how do we go from this to this?
From a pile of bones
to a fully functioning biological entity?
And really more to the point,
what kind of science is involved
in reconstructing the
biological attributes
of extinct animals?
Well, where do we start?
We start with bones in the
ground, which we remove
and carefully clean and which
we may mount in museums.
We still kind of have a pile of bones,
although maybe arranged in
a more life-like manner.
In many cases, the bones themselves
hide away their secrets within the rock
in which they're entombed.
And I call all of these dinosaurs here,
analog dinosaurs, 'cause they
live in real physical space
and you can touch 'em and
smell 'em and taste them,
and I love analog dinosaurs,
but there's a lot that
you can't do with them.
And so we've made the jump
into the digital realm
where you can take a
skull like this T-rex here
and run it through a CT
scanner at your local hospital,
or in this case, one of NASA's
rocket engine CAT scanners.
And that step transfers
that analog dinosaur
into the digital realm.
And once it's in your computer,
you can spin it around and
look at from all angles,
which is pretty handy
'cause a lot of these
guys get pretty heavy.
But the real advantage in all of this
is that you can look
inside all of those secrets
that have been kept away from our eyes
for millions of years are now revealed.
That dusty pile of bones
starts to come alive,
brimming even, dripping with biology.
So if soft tissues are so important,
and dinosaur fossils are
just a collection of bones,
how do we get that soft tissue information
that is so important?
Well, obviously we need to look at animals
that still have all of
those soft tissues intact
and those are animals living today.
So here are what we extant animals.
So here is dinosaurs
typified by T Rex, of course,
and where it fits into
phylogeny or the tree of life.
Birds are most closely related.
Birds are in fact a kind of dinosaur.
And then things like crocodilians
and turtles and lizards
and mammals are more distantly related.
But really the present
is the key to the past.
It's kind of a slogan,
but what it really means
is that if you're interested in dinosaurs,
you can't just look at dinosaurs,
you gotta have one foot in the past,
but you got to have the other foot
firmly planted in the present.
And so our methods run from the classical
to the cutting edge,
we use such time-honored
old fashioned techniques
like the section and vascular
injection and sectioning,
trying to understand the structures
of modern day relatives of dinosaurs,
really trying to give
us ideas and information
on the relationships of the
soft tissues to the bones
that we can then check
for in the dinosaurs.
And one thing I'll quickly point out
is that all the animals,
all the modern day animals
that we get in are what are
called salvage specimens,
salvage carcasses that died somewhere else
for some other reason or were euthanized
and then were donated
to our lab for research.
But we also use the latest technology
with CT scanning to get
inside the heads of dinosaurs.
CT scanning is an x-ray modality
developed for use in hospitals
and we do a lot of scanning at hospitals,
but many universities like
Ohio University and Yale
have high resolution micro-CT scanners
that are also very helpful for us.
So CT is actually a wonderful thing
if you want to visualize bones
and teeth, the hard tissues.
But one of the problems with CT
is that it's not so great
at visualizing soft tissues.
So if we take this lovely
little crocodile skull
or head here and run a slice through it,
you can see that all the soft tissues
basically just wind up being
a sort of indistinct gray.
We need some way to enhance the contrast
so we can actually see
what's going on in 3D.
So it turns out that administering iodine
has been a game changer for the study
of a lot of this morphology,
because iodine differential binds
to different soft tissues
such that we can now see,
it's not indent gray, we can
see just about everything.
It's really quite remarkable
the detail that we can get.
Well, we don't see exactly everything
that we'd like to see,
because our lab is also
interested in blood vessels,
the blood vascular system
and how blood is shunted around the body.
And we'll talk about this a
fair amount as we go in today.
So for example, what we do
is we can take a carcass
that was donated to us of
a pelican, in this case,
and inject its, we can use
barium, which is a chemical
that shows up on CT scans
and we can inject it
into the arteries and veins
and then subject it to CT scanning.
So if we look at some slices
here through this pelican,
we can see that we've got
nice bright white arteries and gray veins,
so we can distinguish
between arteries and veins.
You can see that the muscle and the bone
is much less dense and
sort of a darker gray.
If we look closer, we can actually see
that we've got veins
surrounded by arteries
as well as arteries within veins.
That's really exciting for us,
because it opens up the possibility
of having some physiological role here,
particularly with regard to heat exchange
and shuttling heat and
cool around the body.
Again, this is something
we'll talk about today
when we get to our dinosaurs.
And so we've been using these techniques,
for example, our vascular techniques.
We starting to explore the
physiological significance
of these using thermal imaging.
And so in this case, we
were actually following up
on the pelican example,
we're able to actually show
how blood that's cooled in
the pouch of the pelican
actually can be routed back to the brain
to help moderate brain temperatures.
And so these kinds of approaches wind up
being important for us.
And so this is just a summary slide
showing the various kinds of
techniques and visualizations
that we can do.
We still do lots of old school dissection.
We do that all the time.
It's absolutely essential.
But these new techniques
have been so important.
We scientists often like to throw around
the term transformative,
particularly in our grant proposals,
(audience laughs)
but CT scanning has
really been transformative
for the science of anatomy and morphology
and how it functions.
So how can these techniques
to help us understand
soft tissues help us
actually flesh out dinosaurs?
Hollywood can just make stuff up.
Looking at you "Jurassic
World," but as scientists,
we need testable hypotheses
grounded in the structure of the fossils
as well as their modern day relatives.
Well, let's have a look and focus on
this long neck sauropod
dinosaur, diplodocus.
So of course we start
with the fossil itself,
but the fossils are often distorted
or they're missing
parts or they're broken,
whether by nature or by human hands.
What we really want is
the actual pristine skull
that was in the animal's
head when it was alive
so that we can build the
soft tissues on that.
This skull looks pretty nice and it is,
but it's been living under a mountain
for the past 150 million years
and is just kind of beat up.
So what we can do then is by CT scanning,
we can pull that analog skull
into a digital environment
and once it's a computer,
hopefully we can start to fix it
to reverse the ravaging
effects of of time.
That is, we can then use computer software
like Maya or ZBrush to correct distortion
to replace missing bones,
to fix broken elements.
Starting to bring that thing back into
what we might call the
skull that the animal had.
And this winds up being a key thing.
Now you may quibble about
any of the decisions
that we made in making this skull,
but given the vast variation
within the natural population
of diplodocus 150 million years ago,
I'm pretty sure there was a skull
that looked pretty much just like this.
In fact, this skull is
really no longer CM11161.
It's basically just
diplodocus at this point.
And so now that we've
got a complete skull,
we can start to hang
some soft tissues on it.
So what we're gonna do is
sort of try to understand
how we can flesh out this head.
And now if you think about
it, within our heads,
there's sort of two classes
of soft tissues that we have.
We've got those that are sort
of sitting within cavities
like our brain or the things
within our nasal cavity,
and we have things that span
bones, like the jaw muscle.
Well, let's start with the
first one, things within bones,
because those are a little easier.
So we can take a skull, I like diplodocus,
it's actually a different skull
than the one we just looked at.
And we can run it through a CT scanner
like we did here and
then digitally slice it,
revealing a really nice cavity
in the back of the skull
that's filled with rock.
We can then use software
to digitally isolate or highlight,
segment is the term we
use in the business here,
that structure that we
now call a brain endocast.
We then use the information we gained
and experience gained from looking at
the modern day relatives
of dinosaurs to figure out
what parts of that pertain to the brain
versus nerves versus blood vessels.
We can do the same thing
with our modeled diplodocus,
and you can actually see
this is again based on
numerous specimens where we've looked at
not just that one specimen,
but every specimen we could find.
We're constantly referring to things
like the specimens cast of
them, CT scan data, photographs,
the literature that allows
us to restore these things
such that now that we can
restore the brain endocast
of diplodocus completely and
we can actually extract it,
view it from all angles
and even 3D print it
if we so choose.
And so if we think about some of these
well constrained structures,
they include what we just talked about,
which is this brain
endocast in the back there,
also some other pretty
well constrained structures
like a cartilaginous nasal septum,
the same septum that we have,
like somebody has a deviated
septum, it's the same septum
as well as this air sinus right in there.
And also portions of things
like blood vessels and nerves
that sort of lie within
grooves on the bone
or actually tunnel
through it in bony canals.
But we also have less
constrained structures.
These are the harder
ones to a certain extent,
like some of the blood vessels and nerves
actually pass through open space.
Those parts are a little
harder for us to reconstruct.
Also things like the jaw muscles
that run from the skull
down to the lower jaw.
Also things like the eyeball
and the other contents
within the eye socket
as well as the airway.
And there's more things
that we could add in here
and in fact are, but you can get a sense
as to how all these soft tissues
actually share space within the skull.
Actually all of these ideas here,
all of these soft
tissues that you see here
actually constitute hypotheses
that we can test via
a variety of criteria.
For example, we use bony signatures,
osteological correlates.
These are things like the
scars that muscles leave
or the canals or grooves in the bones
left by blood vessels and nerves.
We can also use phylogenetics and here
we're referring to the
genealogical relationships
of organisms that tell us something
about the expected anatomy.
For example, we'd expect this air sinus
in the front of the snout to be here
because it's a shared attribute
of dinosaurs and their relatives.
So we would expect that to be there.
And finally, packaging.
Packaging constraints wind
up being really important.
The fact that it's all gotta fit
means that all of the
different soft tissue systems
in a sense tell us about themselves.
They tell us about each other,
sort of a process of
reciprocal illumination.
So using these kinds of things,
we can start to flesh these animals out.
A good example of packaging constraints
are in fact the jaw muscles.
And this work actually wound up being
really important to us
as we try to understand
the function of the feeding
apparatus in diplodocus.
'Cause as we were doing this work,
one thing we discovered is
that we actually couldn't get
everything to fit.
We had a problem, particularly
with the jaw muscles.
And so it turns out we, you know,
made all these very careful
and minute adjustments
on positions, making sure they were right.
But we wound up really having
to adjust the thicknesses
of the muscles such
that they wound up being
very thin straps.
And a key thing to remember
about this kind of work
is that in the real world,
muscles actually bulge
when they contract and that
actually winds up being
a key factor when you're
trying to do this kind of work,
because in the real world,
muscles can't be allowed
to intersect or overlap.
In the digital world, you
can let things overlap.
In the real world,
that's not gonna happen.
Also, what shouldn't
happen in the real world
if a muscle bulges, it shouldn't
cause the skull to explode.
(audience laughs)
Important safety tip.
And so that caused us
to adjust our thicknesses even further,
which had some pretty
significant implications
for the biology of these animals.
Just a quick aside here as a
shout out to some of the team
that was involved in helping
us with the early phase
of this visible interactive dinosaur work,
our VID diplodocus.
This is about 10 years ago,
and I'll point out that
four of the grad students
in this photo right here and now
anatomy professors at medical school,
and this woman right here in the middle,
Kate Kirby O'Connell,
is now an animation
supervisor at Disney Studios.
And so she's done amazing things.
And so using these kinds of techniques,
we've actually done more
than just diplodocus.
And so we've actually
restored, more or less,
full head anatomy in a whole
range of different dinosaurs
and we've got some others
that aren't in this image.
And that I'll also point
out and acknowledge
the role of my longtime research associate
and actually research collaborator
on all this, Ryan Ridgely,
and my good friend
for over 20 years who's
helped me work through
all this kind of work.
And so all of these different, in a sense,
to flesh out all of these things
actually winds up being
quite a bit of work.
This very tedious process of
iterative hypothesis testing
and making all of these references
to the structure of the bones
and the relationships of the soft tissues,
all those bony signatures, but
the reality is we can do it,
but what's really exciting
is what we can do with it.
That is how we can use these restorations
to start to explore
things like the function,
physiology, and behavior of these animals.
What we call higher order inferences.
And an obvious one is one
that we just talked about,
which is more realistic modeling
of jaw and muscle movements.
Like just like we saw here in diplodocus.
And I pointed out that our work
on this sort of restoration of diplodocus
required us to have really,
really thin muscles,
which was very curious to us.
At the time, Eric Snively
was a postdoc in my lab
and Eric is really
interested in engineering
and engineering approaches.
And so he wanted to have a look at this.
And so what he did was
he actually measured
the lengths and volumes of
all of these jaw muscles
so he could calculate muscle forces.
And what he found was that the bite,
he was really interested
in using an approach
called finite element analysis,
which is an engineering approach
that tells us something
about stresses and strains
in skulls and actually tells
us something about bite force.
And bite force is a
very important parameter
for any animal really.
And so what Eric found was that
the bite force of diplodocus
was actually just a quarter, one fourth,
of what we thought it was
before we did all this work.
And so Eric's work has been
very helpful, very important.
Here is one of these finite
element analysis illustrations,
an animation showing areas of high stress
and the hot colors show
where stresses are very high
and that's gonna have a big impact
on what it's going to mean for bite force.
And so our studies showed that diplodocus
had a much weaker skull
than what we had thought in the past.
And in the past, we thought
it had a pretty weak skull.
And so these new findings impact our view
on what the behavior in
biology of diplodocus
must have been.
Another project, again, this one
was also led by Eric Snively,
involved looking at restoring
lots of the soft tissues
in the head and the neck of
a Jurassic predatory dinosaur
called Allosaurus, based
on a famous specimen
known as Big Al.
And what we used was borrowing
another engineering approach,
something from robotics,
called quantitative multi-body dynamics.
And so we reconstructed, for example,
things like the air sinuses and the snout
and the attachments of the neck muscles
and basically ran all of these analyses.
And cutting to the chase, one
of the things we discovered
is that Allosaurus's head and neck
actually had something called
a low rotational inertia.
That's jargon, but what it
means is that Allosaurus
could move its head around
with a lot of flexibility and control.
We also found, it was
an unexpected finding,
that there was an unusual
attachment of a neck muscle
that indicates that may have had
a sort of an unusual or different approach
for removing flesh from a carcass
where it would actually use
sort of a tugging action
like we saw just there
something that we see
the falcons do today,
this tug or axial tearing
rather than something like
a lateral shake of the head,
which is what alligators do
and is in fact what our studies showed
that T-rex did as well.
So we're able to use
these kind of approaches
to kind of drill down onto
some fairly fine grain aspects
of feeding behavior in this case.
All right, well let's
actually transition away
from feeding biomechanics for a second
and go back to physiology.
One thing I mentioned before
that these vascular injections
allow us to, in a sense,
look at patterns of heat flow,
because the blood vessels
actually shuttle blood around
the body to warm and cool certain areas.
This is something we know
from our own experience.
On a really hot day,
we will become flushed.
Our our skin will be turned red
as we shunt blood to the
skin to radiate heat.
Likewise, what we saw, just to remind you
of our pelican here, where we discovered
that there were venous blood
that was cooled in the
pouch was routed to the head
to moderate brain temperatures
and keep the animals from overheating.
And so these vascular injection approaches
really played into our
dinosaur research in a big way
with the work of my
former doctoral student,
Ruger Porter and his studies
of dinosaur vasculature
and brain cooling.
And here's the problem,
and it's very well known.
Dinosaurs were big.
They were ridiculously big in many cases.
What that means is that they had
a low surface to volume ratio.
And how you can envision that
is like a big pot of stove
or a big pot of chili on your stove.
Large things heat up and
cool down very slowly
as opposed to like these little dinosaurs,
you can see there on the right,
which are sort of more
like your a cup of coffee
that gets cold as soon as
you turn your back on it
due to their high
surface to volume ratios.
So dinosaurs had these high heat loads.
They would've been a big heat sink.
And one consequence of that is
that hot blood from the core
would rush to the head
and potentially damage
the heat sensitive brain and
sensory tissues located there.
And so as a result,
dinosaurs must have had
some kind of physiological mechanisms
to protect and cool
those sensitive organs.
We know that in modern day animals,
blood vessels form heat exchangers.
And so Ruger's project was largely to try
and identify sites of heat
exchange in these dinosaurs.
Just as the evaporation
of our sweat on a hot day
cools us down, animals
use evaporative cooling
just as we do.
And so we targeted three main sites
of evaporative cooling in
the head that animals have,
including the mouth or the oral region,
the nasal region or nose,
as well as the eyes and eyelids,
within the eye socket or the orbit.
As always, what we do is
we ground our inferences
in the the modern day
relatives that we see here,
and we did, I don't know,
dozens and dozens of injections
of modern day animals.
In all cases, trying to document
not just the blood vessels themselves,
but also their bony signatures,
the osteological corals,
the grooves and canals
that we can then check for
in the dinosaurs so we
can start to reconstruct
dinosaur vascular anatomy as well.
And so basically what we found is
as a modern day species today,
blood would've been cooled,
venous blood would've been cooled
in these same three
sites of heat exchange.
In the nose, the mouth,
and in the eye socket.
And sure enough, what we found
were evidence of rich vascular plexes
in the nose and in the roof of the mouth
where venous blood would've been cooled
by evaporative cooling and
then routed back to the brain
via a variety of different routes.
And so this information
showed us that Majungasaurus
and Diplodocus indeed,
probably more dinosaurs,
maybe all dinosaurs, had
the vascular machinery
to help regulate their brain temperature.
In a sense, solving or
addressing a problem
associated with their large body sizes.
And so although it looks
like all of these dinosaurs
probably had all these three
sites of heat exchange,
some dinosaurs or groups of dinosaurs
actually emphasized
different blood vessels.
They had different thermal strategies.
For example, something like
diplodocus and Majungasaurus
actually seemed to have a
sort of a balance strategy,
meaning that all three
sites of heat exchange
actually seem to be important,
whereas some actually
emphasized one site or another.
For example, Camarasaurus,
the large bodied sauropod dinosaur,
really emphasized the mouth,
the oral site of heat exchange,
whereas the armored
dinosaur, Euoplacephalus
here on the left actually did the reverse
and was very much using
its nose and nasal region
as a heat exchanger, an air conditioner.
And so these kinds of approaches
have been very, very helpful.
As a brief aside,
I'll point out that actually in 2020,
National Geographic did a major
roundup of dinosaur research
and they actually featured this project
in a two page infographic right here.
And here are our guys right here
is Euoplacephalus and
Camarasaurus and Majungasaurus
And so it was pretty
cool that they did that.
In fact, I really liked their title
and so I stole it for my slides.
Don't tell 'em.
(audience laughs)
It's cleverer than I am.
So kind of a similar kind of project
was actually trying to
understand patterns of airflow
through the snouts of dinosaurs.
Ryan Ridgeley and I,
a number of years ago,
did a project where we're
pretty well nailed down
where all the airspace were
within the snouts of a lot of dinosaurs.
And in some something like Euoplacephalus,
this ankylosaur, had a
really unusual nasal cavity
with all these twists and turns in it
that suggesting that it ran right next to
all those blood vessels
that we just talked about,
suggesting a potential
role in in heat exchange
and potentially even metabolic physiology.
We also modeled airflow with regard to
the sense of smell, or olfaction,
as we did here in T-Rex.
And we like to think this was in advance,
but this was 15 years ago
and we were basically just drawing arrows.
We're in a 3D virtual environment,
we should be able to to to model it.
And so actually Jason Bourke,
another former PhD student in my lab,
wanted to tackle this project
using another engineering approach
called computational fluid dynamics.
And I think our lab may
have been among the first
to actually start using CFD on animals.
And Jason's been very busy over the years
doing lots of modeling of airflow
in lots and lots of
different kinds of animals.
And I'll point out that
actually just about
all of these are firsts,
the first time that any bird
has had its airflow modeled
or reptile or extinct animal of any kind.
And if you look closely
you can actually see
the air moving around in there
and it's actually telling us
something about the speed.
And one of the things that we can see here
that in all these cases,
we get faster airflow in the main airway
as it goes from the nostril
down into the throat
and much slower airflow in the
back part of the nasal cavity
where smelling takes place.
And it's been thought for some time
that these slower air speeds
in the olfactory chamber
in a sense allow the
olfactorant molecules.
These are little particles of smell.
You may not think about
smell as being particles,
but there are little particles of smell
that find their receptors
and the slower air speeds are
thought to make that easier.
And Jason's research actually,
his modeling shows that very, very nicely.
So we wanted to apply this
approach on an extinct animal,
in this case, and again,
Jason led this project
and this project focused
on pachycephalosaurs,
which are the bony headed dinosaurs.
In this case, Stegoceras.
Pachycephalosaurs are
actually a great group
to work on lots of things
that involve soft tissues
because they ossified
so many different kinds of soft tissues
that other kinds of dinosaurs didn't.
So if we take the skull
and slice it in half,
we can of course see
this big thick bony dome
on top of its head that
gives these animals its name,
but also what we can
see is in the back part
of the nasal cavity, right in here,
are preserved unexpectedly a
series of scrolled portions
of mineralized cartilage.
These are something you would
actually call turbinates.
Turbinates, because the
scrolls sort of look like
the veins on a turbine.
And so they're in the region
where smelling takes place,
so we call these old factory turbinates.
One thing we also found was a ridge
that runs right down the main
part of the nose right there
in the main airway that almost certainly
had some kind of a
turbinate attached to it.
The key thing here is that
that ridge right there
is in the main airway.
And so any turbinate in there
would be a respiratory turbinate.
And the significance there
is that respiratory turbinate
have been sort of really
thought to be important
in metabolic physiology,
because warm-blooded
or endothermic mammals and birds
have those kinds of structures,
respiratory turbinates.
So turns out that we have
all these structures too
and so we can sort of see the
turbinate there in a skull.
In life, those are actually
covered with a mucus membrane,
in which case we call those conchae.
And these conchae and turbinate
are actually involved in
warming and humidifying
and filtering the inspired air,
but also this is where a
lot of the heat exchange
is going too.
Recall, this is one of those
three sites of heat exchange
along with the oral cavity and the orbit.
Now the mucosa, the mucus membranes
are long gone in the fossils.
That rots away quickly, but we
might be able to get a handle
on the turbinate.
And so that was what we set
out to do with Stegosaurus
and we actually tested
a variety of hypotheses
versus a series of criteria.
And I'll just focus on one criterion
because it's sort of interesting in that
there should be some amount
of olfactory airflow,
some air going back into
that olfactory chamber in Stegosaurus.
And the reason for that is that we see
that it's got really large
olfactory bulbs in the brain.
In other words, the
neural part of the brain
that's actually associated
with the sense of smell.
And again, there's also
those well-developed olfactory turbines.
So there should be olfactory airflow.
The kicker was when we
actually ran the analysis
in the absence of any kind of turbinate
in that main airway space there,
we actually had no olfactory airflow.
In fact the inspired air
just completely bypassed
the olfactory region,
suggesting that there must be
some kind of turbinate in there
if only to act as a baffle to direct air
towards that old factory region.
So we can sort of look at
this, the skull right here,
again, this is cut in half
and we do have evidence,
we have that nice ridge right there
that's very similar to the
kind of turbinate ridges
we see in mammals, in birds.
And so that gives us the
opportunity to, in a sense build,
well, actually you can see
where that ridge right here
as we sliced through the skull right here,
you can see that ridge,
that same ridge right
in there in the fossil,
and what we did then was to actually model
in a turbinate attaching to
the length of that ridge.
We actually modeled multiple
different sort of confirmations
or shapes of that turbinate
including being scrolled
or being branched,
which we borrowed actually literally
from a turkey and an ostrich.
It turns out that the
branched confirmation,
the turkey turbinate,
actually performed better,
but the reality is we don't really know
what that turbinate looked like,
'cause we just have the ridge.
But it turns out that with the analysis,
it doesn't really matter,
because any of the confirmations we used
actually restored olfactory airflow.
And so what we can see
here is that the presence
of the ridge gives us the
general size and position
of where that turbinate is,
and the computational
fluid dynamics analysis
showed us that there must have been
some kind of turbinate in that position
regardless of what its shape is.
And it's kind of interesting
by modeling different shapes
that the specific shape doesn't
really matter that much.
So there are things that we can't know,
but what's useful for
us to try to figure out
is how much do we actually need to know?
And so we know enough
that there must be something
else going on in there.
And so in the publication we talked about
the physiological implications of this,
what it might mean for, you know,
warm bloodedness and metabolic physiology.
But it was also, we're
also really interested
in highlighting, at least to us,
this this notion that's kind
of obvious in retrospect,
but overlooked, which is that turbines
also perform the function
of acting as baffles
to move airflow throughout
the nasal region.
So stepping back and just looking at this,
this is actually, you know, an animal
that lived during the Cretaceous
and we're doing some fairly
refined knowledge of,
or fairly refined studies
trying to understand how
these animals worked.
And we can do that once we're
in this digital environment.
Let's go back to the armored dinosaurs,
Ankylosaurs, again.
If you recall I mentioned
that Euoplocephalus
had this long, really convoluted airway,
sort of like the crazy straw
that kids have if you
remember crazy straws.
And so we were interested in
actually what this might mean
in terms of heat exchange,
in terms of warming and
humidifying inspired air,
and at the same time,
recapturing moisture and heat
during exhalation.
And we had a great team to,
to pull this together again,
we had Jason Burke doing the
computational fluid dynamics
and Ruger Porter with his
work on the vasculature.
And this model right here
shows one of the results of this work,
which actually shows a
remarkably efficient system
for actually in fact warming
the air and humidifying it
on its way down to the lungs.
So if we look at this slide here,
which is a a little complicated,
this actually represents one of the ways
that we actually assess efficiency.
In this case we were
looking at the efficiency
of reclaiming heat when
the animal exhales.
And actually if we look at this image
at the top left right there,
that's basically what the fossil gave us.
In a sense that's the bony bounded thing.
If we just fill it up and look at that,
that's what the fossil looks like.
And that's actually not bad.
That's hovering around 70% efficiency.
One cool thing about being
in in the digital environment
is that we can actually generate anatomy
that nature never did.
And so this top middle image right there
is one where Jason basically took out
all the convolutions and made
the nasal cavity much shorter
such that the airway went from the nostril
down into the throat just
like we saw in stegosaurus
and just like in in us.
And you can see right there
that the efficiency plummets
to less than 30% if you do that.
This one at the bottom
is sort of interesting.
This is one where we said,
"okay, well let's keep
all the length and we'll just get rid of
all the convolutions,
just make it a long
straight narrow thing."
And what we can see there
is actually this way better,
at about 60%, it's way
better than the short airway,
but not quite what we
see up with the fossil,
the as preserved in the fossil airway,
which that tells us that the convolutions
actually make a difference.
The convolutions probably
relate to vortices or vortexes
of air, and as they go
around those curves,
that actually apparently
makes a difference.
On the top right there though,
that's one where we
actually went a step further
and actually restored the soft tissues.
We actually put the
mucus membranes back in
and at that point the efficiency sores up
to around 80 plus percent right there.
So these kinds of approaches
allow us to, in a sense,
do simulations and experiments
within a computer environment
that give us a glimmer
into how these animals
may have actually worked.
And stepping back a little bit,
one of the things that's
sort of interesting
is that ankylosaurs like Europlocephalus
don't actually have turbinate
like we saw in stegosaurus
or people in a in a whole
bunch of of other animals.
But what they may have actually
by having this long convoluted airway
is in a sense an alternate
evolutionary solution
to the same physiological problem.
A lot of things ultimately
just matter about surface area,
an expanding surface area
no matter how you do it.
Also, we can see how well
Ruger Porter's work jived
with Jason's work and that we can see
that these blood vessels,
the veins would've actually been cooled
by evaporative cooling as
they're going past all of those,
the mucosa within those
that convoluted airway,
and then that cooled blood routes back
towards the brain to help
moderate brain temperatures.
And I think John Ostrom
would've loved all this.
I think he would've, John
was actually a geologist,
but he was also a hardcore
anatomist as well.
And so going back to his
doctoral dissertation in 1961
that was looking at these crazy crests
on the heads of duckbill
dinosaurs like Corythosaurus,
he actually did a lot of
work with modern day animals.
So he was looking at things
like jaw muscles and brains
and airways in animals
that are around today
so that he could interpret his fossils.
That's exactly what we do today,
we've just got different tools,
we've got more advanced tools to do that.
And John's work has been
absolutely foundational
for work that we've
done sort of, you know,
21st century kind of stuff looking at
the structure and
development of these airways
and as well as the brain in Corythosaurus
as well as some of its other animals.
And this is a good sort of lead in
to another benefit of these
very visual 3D restorations
is that it's really good way
to reach out to the public
with our science because
they're so visible
and so easy to understand.
Again, in the the 2020
National Geographic,
they did another infographic on our work,
in this case of a cousin of Corythosaurus
called Hypachrysaurus
looking at the airway,
but also the brain and sensory systems
and our also our work on Parasaurolophus,
another cousin of Corythosaurus
will actually be appearing
soon in a TV documentary
devoted to some other things.
And that picture at the lower
right there shows me holding
the 3D prints of the skull
and airway of Parasaurolophus
which probably would've just been
an unbelievable thrill for John Ostrom
to have been able to
do something like that.
So in summary, the work
of people like John Ostrom
remains as vital today
as it as it ever has,
and we're just in a sense building on it.
The modern technology has not
replaced it or cast it aside.
Rather, we're using it
as a foundation for us
to actually use these technologies
to actually start to understand
the biology of dinosaurs
by basically putting them
back together in a computer.
And at the same time that really gives us
a new opportunity to
reach out to the public
and talk to them about science
just like we're doing right now.
And thanks for your attention today.
(audience applauds)
I'll just quickly point out,
I took this photo this morning
when I was in working in the collections
over in the Peabody Museum.
- [Moderator] Alright,
thanks so much Larry.
So we will have a question answer session
for about maybe say 10 minutes now.
And what's gonna happen
is I'll call on people
and if you wait until
someone runs up to you
with a microphone so everyone
can hear the question,
that would be great.
Okay, let's go.
Yes, over here.
Please.
- Thank you very much.
Just wondering, and
it's not directly to do
with what you're doing,
but you must have thought about
it, what about intelligence?
Can you say with any
definitiveness that certain species
were more intelligent than
others because of this and that?
- Sure, yeah, yeah.
The question was what can
we say about intelligence
in these animals?
And actually I've been
studying brains in dinosaurs
for a long time.
We've got a major grant
that's looking at cognition
in deep time and intelligence
is a sort of a difficult thing to do
and a lot of cognitive biologists
prefer the term cognition
as to how capable are animals
of solving problems in
learning and things like that.
We colloquially we would call that smart
and the reality is there are differences
among dinosaurs in that capacity.
We always tend to think that animals
just need to be smart enough,
and a key factor in that is that brains
are very expensive organs.
Brains actually cost a lot
of energy that we take in.
And so animals very often need to,
in a sense, evolutionarily
fine tune their brain size
so that they're not in
a sense wasting energy
on cognitive abilities
or neural processing
that they don't need.
And so we see animals like T-Rex
and other predatory dinosaurs tend to have
relatively large brains
'cause they're doing a
lot of neural processing
to be predators.
Whereas something like
diplodocus, bless his heart,
I was going there, has
really quite a small brain,
but the dude was gigantic
and it was just eaten plants
that aren't moving and so
its cognitive requirements
were significantly less.
And so the the notion of
of dinosaur intelligence
is something that our broader team,
it's actually a multinational
team, is actually working on.
So thank you for that question.
- [Moderator] Up here.
Top back.
Way back.
Saw your hand up this whole time.
- [Audience Member] Are you
holding a Dinonicus over there?
- Yeah, yeah.
That's a Dinonicus,
same Dinonicus as John Ostrom right there.
- [Audience Member] Whoa.
- Yep, and that's a
Dinonicus foot right there
with the killing claw.
- [Audience Member] What's that guy?
I thought that was like Velociraptor.
- Well, it's very similar to Velociraptor.
Velociraptor in the
movies is like this big,
in real life it was about this big.
- Yeah.
Before about Hollywood.
- [Audience Member] I
watched the franchise a lot.
(audience laughs)
- You and me both, dude.
- [Moderator] You can
come see that Dinonicus
when the museum reopens, it's here.
Okay, let's see.
How about the back of the front row here?
- [Audience Member] Do
you use to determine
how strong a jaw muscle
to help out determine
how strong a jaw muscle would be,
do you use whether they
would be a carnivore
or a well, word, yeah, herbivore.
That.
That word that I can't pronounce yet.
Okay.
Well, I normally can.
Because the carnivores
might need more jaw muscle
to actually tear the flesh off
whereas the herbivores
wouldn't need to do that.
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So the question was,
well, what kind of muscle force
does it take to be a a
predator or an herbivore?
And the answer as is so true
in much of life is it depends.
And it depends on what
kind of a carnivore you are
and what kind of an herbivore you are.
So for example, if you're T-rex,
an adult T-rex and you are biting bones,
you need big powerful muscles
to actually crack through those bones.
If you are Dinonicus,
your skull is probably adapted
more for removing flesh,
using other ways to kill the animal,
and Dinonicus is actually
a fairly delicate animal
in many ways.
And so it was probably not cracking bones,
something like Allosaurus,
we talked about Allosaurus
and how it was actually pulling back.
And in that case when it was
removing flesh from the bone,
it was actually just
holding on with its teeth
and then muscles that
were actually working
were the neck muscles to pull that back.
Same thing with some of the plant eaters,
something like Diplodocus right here,
basically its teeth are kind of a joke.
They're just these little,
they look like little crayons
that are jammed in the front of its face
that were probably as sort of as rakes
or something to strip branches off.
They were not chewing and
so they had relatively
super weak jaws and bite force.
Whereas there's other
dinosaurs, other plant eaters,
that have really powerful bites,
and particularly if there's animals
that are doing things
like biting repeatedly,
like chewing or cracking seeds,
that requires big, big jaw muscles.
A cardinal at your feeder
has really big jaw muscles
'cause it's cracking
seeds whereas a sparrow
at your feeder doesn't,
'cause it's just picking up
little, little seeds
and chucking them down.
So it depends, but it's a great question.
Thank you.
- [Moderator] Oh, bottom here in the blue.
- [Audience Member] How do you figure out
how to do all of that?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- That may be the best question we get.
How do we figure out how to do all that?
I spent a lot of time explaining that
to that thing that says NSF up there.
(audience laughs)
That's the funding agency.
But that's a great question.
I don't mean to make light of it,
because actually it's kind of hard
to do all this these things
and there's lots and lots of steps
and you saw that I had a lot
of people that I work with,
I work a lot with with graduate students
and undergraduate students, I've even had
high school students working
in my lab and post-docs,
and we work as a team and we
often do different parts of it.
Like you saw, I had one person
that was working really hard
on blood vessels and trying
to figure out where they went.
Another person that was
trying to figure out
how airflow works.
And so all of these team
members get together
and they work as a team.
But it is hard and it
takes us a while sometimes
to actually come up with these things.
Thank you.
That's a great question.
- [Moderator] Lisa, I
have it right next to you.
- You talked about Euoplacephalus
and it's very complicated nasal passages.
Now, in more recent days I've seen
sort of interesting
speculative reconstructions
of Euoplacephalus and
similar inchyalosaurs
with like nasal air sacs
attached to the nostrils
that will inflate and possibly
make a sound to communicate.
Your thoughts on that.
Is that plausible or?
- Sure, yeah.
So the question was some
people have actually suggested
that some dinosaurs could
have had inflatable sacks
that are coming out of their nose,
which sounds pretty crazy,
but animals do crazy things.
And so I mean what
Euoplacephalus does without that
is pretty crazy, so if Euoplacephalus
had inflatable nose sacks,
that would be maybe right
in line for that animal.
The reality is some of these things
are pretty hard for us to get at.
The person that actually
presented the notion of that
for I think like triceratops
and its relatives,
a ceratopsian, I'm not sure he was,
I think he was being a little
whimsical when he did that.
But the fact of the matter
is inflatable display organs
are used all the time
in the animal kingdom.
I don't know if you've
heard the frogs out yet,
but you get the peepers and
they'll be actually doing it
in many species that are
actually brightly colored.
There are things like elephant
seals and hooded seals
that actually have inflatable nose bags
that come off of their,
apparently the females just love it.
There's no accounting for taste.
And so could some of
these dinosaurs have it?
The answer is maybe,
and those are the kind of questions
that actually we are trying to get at.
One of the things we've discovered
over the course of time is that a lot of,
in sort of in some respects
my basic job has become
is where is the limit of what we can know?
It turns out a lot of the
really interesting things
are like right out there.
They're just beyond the
limits of what we can know.
What's interesting is that
technology like CT scanning
and all these other techniques going boom,
all of a sudden we've
got some new techniques
that we can start to know
more than what we thought.
And also just making
the right comparisons.
Actually starting to look at,
we've actually dissected
hooded seals and elephant seals
'cause we have actually are
interested in that question.
I have come to learn to
never say never about life,
because life just evolves
all of these different kinds of organisms.
Thank you.
That's a good one.
- [Moderator] Okay.
How about front and center here?
Or at least having you run all around.
- [Audience Member] Thanks.
So I guess something I'm wondering about,
we know that dinosaurs I think at least
became warm-blooded over time.
I'd imagine from a heat
exchange standpoint
those would be, you know,
kind of different heat exchange problems
when you're dealing with
a cold-blooded creature
versus a warm-blooded one.
Do you see any like evidence of changes
in sort of the heat exchange
efficiency over time?
- Well, so the question
was with the evolution
of warm bloodedness or
endothermic, you know,
would that occur over time
and what would we see changes in that?
It's a great question.
It's a difficult one, but one
that we've thought a lot about
and often it's not so much over time,
often it's within different groups.
Different groups will often
have different strategies.
And so the reality is it's really hard
to be warm-blooded like we are.
I mean it's actually hard
to maintain body temperature
at a peak rate and there's lots of costs
that go around with that,
like breathing fast.
We breathe faster than
cold blooded animals.
And that's actually a lot of these things
that we're looking at in terms
of reclaiming heat and water.
It's 'cause we breathe really fast
and you can actually dehydrate yourself
when you breathe too fast.
And so we are actually indeed trying
to look at those structures.
What's interesting is that a lot of these,
we think about hot-blooded dinosaurs,
a lot of the things we're looking at
are things that are because
dinosaurs are too hot-blooded.
In other words, endothermia
makes some of these things worse.
If you're a big dinosaur like Diplodocus
or any of these guys where
you're just a giant heat sink
with the sun coming down on you,
heating you up, you're gonna be hot
whether you're generating heat internally
like a warm blooded, you
know, an endoderm does,
you're gonna be hot anyways.
And so these kinds of physio,
we call them physiological devices,
things that you can use to, in a sense,
deal with these heat problems
are gonna be true for so
many of these dinosaurs.
What's interesting is we find evidence
of a pretty legit nasal,
a respiratory turbinate
in this little Stegosaurus
which was right down here,
which doesn't have the
big overheating problem.
If anything, that guy would
get chilly from time to time.
It was cold.
And so there's a decent
chance of something like that
it were endothermic, it
would've had the machinery
to actually help deal with that.
- [Moderator] Okay.
All right, we're getting
close to past 10 after now,
and with great apologies.
I think we're gonna have to cut it off.
Thank you so much.
(audience claps)